hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we have tons of info on a new
event called a polygons legacy I'm gonna
be talking about it while the trailer is
in the background so let's not waste any
time let's get started so first up this
event is gonna be starting February 15th
to March 8th in February 15th is today
so it's gonna be starting from now until
March 8th is a three week event call
like I said called the apollyon legacy
event this is going to be one of those
other events similar to the winter and
Halloween event except a special
game-mode where you fight against the
bosses of the story mode in a
elimination game this reminds me of man
versus machine if you've ever played tf2
but just a tad bit different the game
will get harder every week to the first
week so basically from today up until
next Thursday it's gonna be a little bit
easier but then slowly gets harder every
week the date the devs said that they're
going to continuously update this
game-mode to make it more difficult
every week for the rewards you're gonna
be getting an outline for logging on
it's got a polygons head or on the
outline which looks absolutely amazing
and an emblem and an emblem reward for
winning I wish it was a little bit
swapped because the the outline looks
really cool and that's gonna start
losing value because of how many people
are just gonna log in and grab it but
that's up to them to decide according to
the dev some of them haven't even beaten
this mode themselves so this may be a
tad bit difficult but it's probably
nothing we haven't dealt with before but
for this you have different teams to
fight against the samurai the Knights
and the Vikings each team has its own
different bosses Emperor chosen Rangga
siege or oh and Okuma for the samurai
apollyon holding crossed mercy in stone
for the knights gudem and our Ragnar
Runa and sieve for the Vikings so shout
outs a stone and holdin I know you guys
watch my videos so congrats on making it
to the event but those are gonna be the
bosses you're gonna be fighting
throughout the event I know I butchered
these names probably but they are
basically the notable characters from
the campaign if you played it the fight
will get harder the more rounds you win
by changing their HP their damage and
their stamina pool and in the last round
that might get powerful feats like Ken's
days forth feet which is the unblockable
for every move to make it harder the
more you win these rounds week one
they're gonna be having easier enemies
some level ones and a little bit of
level two's next week they're gonna be
having level twos with a tad bit of
level 3 BOTS and then the final week
there will be having more powerful
enemies probably harder than level 3
bots these moves like I said are going
to be getting very difficult for example
some of the unblockable mu
may not even have the unblockable icon
si will have to know based off of memory
what the move is you can queue up if
you're alone and need some players to
play with or to grab a few friends and
grab those rewards next up they
mentioned is going to be a polygons
atmosphere there's gonna be some new
music and the face off screen as well
and in the main menu and the face off
screen is also going to be on fire and
these soldiers are going to be having
black outfits so that's going to be a
little bit of a different change and
apollyon will also be the game announcer
for the rounds calling out round 1 round
2 and stuff like that throughout the
match like if the timer is gone and all
that other stuff which is absolutely
incredible
continuing on they showed off the four
honor road map in February 15th which is
today is going to be coming with tribute
rank season 5 rework switch we've talked
about the past two weeks as well as a
double xp fest coming tomorrow and
lasting the whole weekend community
event tomorrow will be to play the test
your metal mode which is the three week
event we just talked about and the
dedicated servers on February 19th for
PC with double loot and double steal in
the coming weeks after that and of
course more community rewards which you
have to contribute to to actually earn
steal this time you can't just have the
community do it and then you reap off
the rewards you have to contribute at
least one mode one execution whatever
that happens to be you have to
contribute at least one to earn this
deal next up is limited time cosmetic
loot will be released in for honor
during the event basically the armor
sets are going to be black and gold for
that apollyon aesthetic as well as black
and gold weapons for the event as well
I believe the dev said that it's the
weapons are going to be versions of the
ones that are going to be releasing in
season 5 that I may have showed a couple
weeks ago in my video but they're going
to be black and gold painted I wasn't
entirely sure but to get these weapons
you're going to need to play the apology
ons legacy event and they will also be
in lieu crates as well so definitely use
those while you have the chance because
they will disappear forever if you don't
grab them so these are the weapons that
are going to be in golden black and they
look absolutely amazing the first batch
of screenshots that I grabbed from the
stream our warden peacekeeper law
bringer in conch the second batch is
gladiator Nobu shishu go key in shinobi
and the last batch was Raider warlord
and shaman now obviously every other
character also that I didn't mention
also got weapons I just couldn't grab
screenshots in time to get the armor
color you're going to need to put on
black the black and gold armor you're
gonna get with the black iron material
as well as the new
or color to get the best black and
golden material possible according to
the Deb's if you want to rock that
outfit and going off the armor the first
batch of photos is going to be warden
Kent's a conquer and law bringer and the
second batch of photos is going to be
Nobu she shinobi Highlander and
gladiator like I said previously every
single character is going to get it I
just didn't grab the screenshots for
every character I didn't have enough
time there is a lot of weapons and armor
but don't worry the devs are working on
a way to add more inventory slots for
your characters and they said what
they're doing what they did from the
last event is if you have a rep worn
Raider and you happen to get one of the
new black and gold weapons and it's only
blue what you plan on repping up Raider
all the way to rep 9 but you won't be
able to get the teal version the very
high tier version they're going to
they're going to come out with a system
so that you can take that blue black and
gold item and bring it all the way up
through the ranks because it is a
special event item emotes are also going
to be looted which is really cool as
well since it's the first time ever that
emotes are available to be looted
there's only going to be one though and
it's called the I M or emo but it still
looks really damn nice there's also
going to be colors and embossing x' as
well and an apollyon alpha which is the
content of the week this week that will
show her mask and come with a new effect
which I will show right now
[Music]
I don't know about you guys but that was
really beautiful everything in this
event except the mask outfit which I
just showed is free since you but you
have to lose every single item to get
those the mask outfit will be costing
fifteen thousand steal for the first
week and then go to twenty thousand
steal the week after as well as a bundle
to get the items for your character now
I know there's been a lot of new players
so I'll try to explain this usually
there's going to be a bundle for every
single character and in the game so
let's take our Musha for example the
bundle is going to be costing
twenty-five thousand steal and that is
the max price but let's say I get the
mask outfit for our Musha the price goes
down so that you don't have to pay
double
even though let's say you have every
single thing for the bundle except one
little emo and then you have to pay
twenty five thousand steal for it that's
not how this works
every time you get something regarding
that bundle for that character the price
will go down so you're not getting cheap
doubt and paying twice for the same
thing so that's why to get the armor and
the weapons you're going to need to play
the character you want it for as well
just like always and there also be a new
emote next week and a secret one in week
three as well but they didn't show what
it was going to be for both of them so
definitely get those as well and they
will be costing 7000 steal as opposed to
the normal 10k because there's going to
be two emotes in a row instead of one
and we're gonna be wasting a lots of
steal in this event so definitely if you
want to get a steal pack or start
grinding definitely get on that right
away and that's it that's the entire
event that they talked about there is a
few things that they didn't show in the
stream because they wanted to keep it as
a secret but either way guys if you did
enjoy the video please sure to give it a
like I really appreciate you guys
sticking around subscribe if you're new
I covered the news the leaks the info
for honor just like this video so
definitely subscribe if you're new my
two most recent videos are gonna be on
screen if you didn't miss those go check
them out and with that guys hope you
have a great rest of your day
enjoy that event and peace out guys see
you later